we said yesterday that the
election lawsuits have not worked out
particularly well for president trump
there is one big one left though
there is a huge one left and this has to
go to the supreme court
in the sense that it's a state suing
other states
so before there's even the chance that
this case could be heard youtube is
saying
if you question anything about the 2020
presidential election
you'll be kicked off of youtube i don't
know if this video is going to be on
youtube right now
i'm just reading the news but the news
is contradicting youtube's
preferred political narrative so i don't
know maybe they're going to kick me off
here's the
order from youtube quote yesterday was
the safe harbor deadline
for the united states presidential
election and enough states have
certified their election results
to determine a president-elect given
that
we will start removing any piece of
content uploaded today or anytime
afterward that misleads people by
alleging that widespread
fraud or errors changed the outcome of
the 2020 u.s
presidential election in line with our
approach toward historical
u.s presidential elections
okay fair enough i mean not really fair
enough it's a stupid rule
but if they really held every political
candidate
to this standard at least it would be
coherent then i was remembering
a couple years ago there was a race in
georgia
for governor between brian kemp and
stacey abrams
and stacey abrams lost that race and
then she and many other people claimed
that she had won that race
and they continued to claim that after
the election was certified
and after brian kemp was sworn in in
fact that election was in 2018.
in july of last year a video was
uploaded to youtube featuring
[ __ ] uger from the young turks and some
other
liberal guy describing how brian kemp
stole that election
so now uh you got unfortunately a
potential
new stolen election and that's uh
georgia
georgia absolutely so what happened is
you know in the case of
uh of georgia uh brian kemp
with the help by the way of his buddy
kris kobach of kansas
um purged um over half a million voters
the race was about a one and a half
point difference but it was actually
much narrower than that when you looked
at what would have required a runoff
yeah it was a few thousand books
just a few thousand votes uh and and
they would have needed a runoff
uh yeah it was look it was a pierce deal
it was a pure steel as of the time of
this airing that video is still on
youtube there's a chance our video is
not on youtube
but that video is on youtube seems like
a double standard now you might say
michael you didn't read carefully enough
because it says that they're going to
take down videos that question the
outcome of the presidential election
not the georgia gubernatorial election
and this is in line with their approach
historically toward
u.s presidential elections okay okay
fine so you can question the results of
other elections
just not the presidential except except
they also question the presidential
election i i
just googled very quickly for a video
that was uploaded fairly recently trump
stole 2016
will he steal the 2020 election this
video is up on youtube today as well
george w bush lost the lost the popular
vote by a half
million votes and his brothers and the
supreme court stole the election for him
in florida
and donald trump lost the popular vote
by three million votes
and you know and frankly i think there
was some nefarious stuff going on in
ohio wisconsin and pennsylvania that
that uh handed the vote to uh to donald
trump
nefarious stuff going on in ohio
wisconsin and pennsylvania in 2016
that handed the vote to donald trump
meaning nefarious right it was
wicked stuff criminal sort of stuff
illegitimate vote
so this guy some liberal guy i haven't
heard of is questioning the results of
the 2020 election and the 2000 election
in the same video but but explicitly the
2020 election
long after that election was certified
so obviously this youtube order is
complete bs
it's not a real standard there is no
historical u.s
presidential election approach and rule
from youtube
they're just instituting this against
conservatives
and to defend liberals so when liberals
say that elections were stolen it's
totally fine
and when conservatives raise any
questions about ongoing litigation
that can and very likely will go to the
supreme court it's the only court that
could hear the case
you're not allowed to say that they'll
take your video down
[Music]
you